[Applauso]
le parole sono importanti ma spesso non
diamo peso le parole perché pensiamo che
in fondo siano fatte di area che durino
poche frazioni di secondo il tempo per
pronunciarle ma le parole sono
importanti
mi ricordo che quando ero bambina forse
come tutti i bambini
mi chiedevo per quale motivo il palio si
chiamasse palo per quale motivo il
marciapiede si chiamasse marciapiede
certo marciapiede una parola composta
marcio a camminare piede ripete che ci
cammina sopra
d'altronde mia madre ancora oggi mi
ripete che quando ero piccola ero
simpatica ed insopportabile con le mie
domande
chiedevo sempre il perché di tutto una
domanda e l'incessante che forse mi ha
portato qui dove sono oggi
per me le parole erano importanti e sono
ancora importanti
tuttavia già anni fa ho imparato ad
accettare i nomi delle cose fisiche che
mi circondano il palo il marciapiede
dell'uci la mano e così via ma continua
a riflettere sui nomi che invece
esprimono concetti astratti quelle cose
che non toccano ma che popolano la
nostra realtà donna uomo cittadino
migrante rifugiato diritti confini
violenza guerra
tutte parole brevi e concise che durano
anche meno della parola marciapiede
eppure non riesco ad accettare la
facilità con cui spesso ed è si
pronuncia
era una bambina quando senti per la
prima volta la parola guerra
era il 1991 e l'allora presidente saddam
hussein iracheno aveva invaso il kuwait
ricordo che i miei genitori rimasero in
piedi tutta la notte incollati davanti
alla tv per capire se l'italia sarebbe
entrata in guerra o meno
io ero né detto né con loro avevo paura
tremavo anche se non sapevo bene che
cosa fosse una guerra ma nel 2003 quando
gli stati uniti dichiararono guerra
all'iraq lì la mia curiosità non sveli
sbagli con il tempo del tg guerra
persone che uccidono altre persone stati
che armano persone per uccidere persone
di altri stati decisi di iniziare a
studiare la lingua araba i nostri tg non
mi bastavano più sapevo che le parole da
noi utilizzate non era
non esaustive non raccontavano tutto
volevo leggere ascoltare come le persone
dall'altra parte del mondo o della
barricata raccontavano una guerra tanti
viaggi e tanto studio in siria palestina
libano turchia ma la mia prima volta in
un paese in guerra come giornalista fu
nel 2011 guerra rivoluzione sommossa
popolare
io e la mia troupe partimmo con un
contatto in tasca un uomo della brigata
tripoli
la brigata che era stata raccontata
dalla stampa internazionale dei
mainstream come la brigata jihadista
fondamentalista ricordo che quando li
poma tripoli
io aspettavo il mio contatto timorosa di
non essere vestita in modo appropriato
stavo per incontrare uno sia lista io
donna mi guardavo intorno e cercavo un
barbuto che prima o poi mi avrebbe detto
con voce espressa sprezzante se tu nancy
la giornalista non andò così mohammed si
presentò con un sorriso accogliente e
dopo qualche imbarazzo iniziale si
mostrò per il ragazzo dolce e un po
perso quale era rivoluzione violenza
anche muhammad mi pare non avesse capito
fino in fondo il significato di queste
parole lui chiedeva solo su un futuro
nel suo paese era perso lui certo da
mariana che fumava con i suoi amici non
lo aiutava a ritrovarsi fumavano tanto e
io pensavo che l'ho finita in un non
luogo uno di quei luoghi che fino ad
allora non esistevano nella mia mappa
concettuale regista libico arabo armato
ma comunque simpatico heavy come la
sensazione di vivere e quello che meno
mi mi avevano raccontato della guerra
contro i nazifascisti
mia nonna non si stancava mai di
raccontarmi la storia della milizia dove
i nazisti fucilarono un centinaio di
civili per vendicare l'uccisione di 10
dei loro uomini
la milizia sì proprio quella l'ingresso
del sasso caveoso che si erge
all'ingresso del di uno dei due sassi
mia nonna me lo raccontava in
continuazione forse perché temeva che le
parole non bastassero per descrivere la
paura allora
e ora io ero con uno di quei ragazzi che
aveva osato combattere il despota come i
partigiani contro i nazifascisti
ma i nazifascisti qui non facevano paura
fu bellissimo quando lo racconta il mio
nonna un giorno d'estate nel suo balcone
sui sassi con muhammad attraversando la
libia in lungo in largo e insieme
finimmo anche nel carcere per detenuti
politici nel quartiere di abu slim nella
capitale tripoli
qui il guardiano usa come violenza
contro i detenuti violava i loro diritti
ma non si nascondeva come succedeva da
noi in italia nel 2011 mi innamorai di
quella terra di nessuno
quella terra dove le parole e concetti
erano rimasti intrappolati
tanto che nel 2013 decisi di trasferirmi
in pianta stabile lì molti dei miei
amici facevano parte delle cosiddette
milizie altri avevano invece preferito
tornare alla loro vita civile
muhammad quello che era venuto a
prendermi la prima volta in libia parti
lui il suo paese non lo riconosceva più
troppa violenza
io invece rimasti in fondo ci era andato
apposta
passarono mesi e poi anni ed io ero in
libia a raccontare il post rivoluzione o
la guerra o quella che era la guerra
civile a posto di produzione gente che
rimaneva in casa per non vedere gente
che preferiva essere in prima linea per
evitare che un odioso fondamentalista
potesse avvantaggiarsi del voto politico
lasciato dalla rivoluzione
tuttavia le mie parole quelle che avevo
a disposizione per raccontare la guerra
ancora sembravano bastarmi milizie
brigate civili società civile per strada
incontravo anche tanti rifugiati
africani e siriani che piano piano si
ammassavano in libia per tentare la loro
traversata verso l'agognata europa
conobbi tanti siriani a tripoli ma per
la stampa internazionale questi non
esistevano così inizia il mio
pellegrinaggio tra le case della
comunità siriano in libia
storie di paura morte e fuga i tuoi
bambini che conobbi nella città di
misurata a fine settembre del 2013
andarono in dispersi in mare nel
naufragio di un barcone il 10 ottobre
successivo
il padre mi chiamo con la voce rotta da
malta mi implorava aiuto mi chiedeva di
contattare le autorità italiane e
chiedere loro se avessero recuperato i
suoi figli ma di muhammad ahmad non si
ebbero più notizie
io e norme decise di superare le mie
paure e mi misi sulle tracce degli
uomini che avevano mandato a morire
muhammad mag
iniziai a chiedere a tutti i miei
contatti in libia se potessero
presentarmi un trafficante uno di quegli
uomini senza scrupoli che mandano la
gente a morire un giorno un mio amico mi
disse che mi avrebbe presentato un
trafficante quello chiamava smuggler o
in arabo murray ed io in italiano
trafficante lo conobbi in una città all
ovest di tripoli
era un caldo pomeriggio del maggio del
ero nervosa anche citata io al cospetto
con un criminale
però lui aveva del deb modi di fare ed
era anche laureato in sociologia aveva
una teoria tutta sua sui migranti i
trafficanti e il flusso migratorio i
migranti secondo lui sbagliavano a
pensare che l'europa fosse il posto
perfetto alla terra dei diritti
secondo lui in europa i migranti
avrebbero continuato a soffrire
semplicemente sofferenze diverse ma
sempre sofferenze e poi mi ripeteva ma
questo non è un mio problema
loro mi chiedono di aiutarli aiutate
attraversare il mare e io mi limito a
fare quello per cui loro mi pagano
l'uomo cattivo quello che per me
rappresentava il traffico degli esseri
umani il giorno dopo giorno si rivelava
una persona ragionevole e incalzava io
sono un semplice fornitore service
provider come si dice in inglese
loro fanno la domanda e io formulo la
mia offerta se lo se loro non sta bene
sono libere di andare da un'altra parte
quante volte ho assistito alle
telefonate di migranti che lo
imploravano di organizzare la traversata
quanto prima
e lui fermo no non si parte questa
settimana nella prossima perché le
condizioni metereologiche non sono buone
a quel punto ero completamente persa
iniziai a pensare che il trafficante non
era poi una persona così cattiva
temevo che l'empatia con questo
personaggio con cui vivevo a casa già da
due settimane mi stesse giocando un
brutto scherzo
anche la sua ragazza era simpatica ed
insieme erano molto carini non era
neanche un maschilista come gli altri
libici pensavo tanti pensavo anche ai
sabati passati a manifestare in piazza
per il diritto di movimento dei migranti
a roma ai comunicati stampa a cui avevo
partecipato quando aggiungeva in europa
la notizia di un naufragio in mare e ora
solidarizzato con un trafficante lo
intervistai anche in uno dei barconi che
avrebbe potenzialmente usato per mandare
i migranti dall'altra parte del
mediterraneo
speravo che almeno li avrei sentito la
puzza di morte di violenza ma anche lì
mi colse di sorpresa dicendomi queste
imbarcazioni arriverebbero e tutte se ci
metti un motore buono e se rispetti la
capienza del barcone rispetto alle alle
persone che ci metti è chiaro che la
gente arriva è solo l'avidità che uccide
la gente poi un giorno si verifica si
verificò naufragio a poche miglia dalle
coste libiche
andrea di incontrare le famiglie
recuperate dai pescatori e dei quarti
coste libici
tentai da giornalista europea armata di
tutte le categorie europee di dare
spazio alla rabbia dei siriani contro il
trafficante che li aveva traditi ma per
l'ennesima volta la parola trafficante
finiva per associarsi a qualcosa di
positivo
le famiglie siriane da me intervistate
si reagirono con grande impeto e mi
dissero che la colpa non era dei
trafficanti che anzi i trafficanti erano
le persone che davano loro la
possibilità di attraversare quel braccio
di mare la colpa risiedeva invece nel
nell'europa che non aveva creato una
zona cuscinetto sicura per loro nel loro
paese
torna in italia essere fatta ai miei
compagni di lotte politiche di una vita
raccontavo di un trafficante di esseri
umani buono i miei compagni facevano
difficoltà a comprenderli l'espressione
per loro come per me era uno skimmer un
ossimoro mi domandai tante volte se non
mi fossi libici data troppo ero in piena
fase di muta mi stavo trasformando stavo
assistendo alla decostruzione
la mia identità quella della retorica
dei diritti con le sue categorie europee
preimpostate
avevo paura paura del vuoto paura che i
miei amici non mi capissero più nel nord
e al sud
mi sentivo un meticcio ma me ne ero
cercata certo ma forse non ero pronta a
quanto stava succedendo frutto del
lavoro sul campo osservazione
partecipata si chiama solo dopo mese ho
capito che quello mogli non era un
trafficante ma un passatore
l'uomo che ha accettato di accogliermi
in casa sua e mostrarmi dietro le quinte
di questo business e come dice lui un
fornitore di servizi non è lui ad
indurre in stato di necessità la
moltitudine di uomini donne e bambini
che decidono di lasciare la propria
terra e affrontare la pericolosa
traversata via mare per giungere
l'europa per giungere in europa
no non è lui lui con il suo business
risponde ad una domanda sul mercato che
induce in stato di necessità questa
moltitudine di genti che si ammassa alle
porte dell'europa sono le politiche di
gestione migratoria dell'unione europea
che davanti ad un cittadino del senegal
del gambia della siria che preferirebbe
entrare regolarmente dichiarando la
propria identità e pagando il proprio
biglietto aereo
chiude loro la porta in faccia niente
visti nelle ambasciate e il passatore
che tante cose mi ha insegnato
aveva ragione soprattutto quando diceva
che anche nel suo business
il problema è l'avidità oggi in libia ci
sono sempre meno passatori è sempre più
trafficanti il passatore li chiama
cavalli pazzi non sanno nulla del mare
una delle tecniche di navigazione ma
approfittando del vuoto di governo che
si è creato nel nella libia post
rivoluzione a mano armata abusano dei
migranti li spostano contro la loro
volontà in questo contesto di viaggi
della speranza attraverso il
mediterraneo sono sempre più pericolosi
gommoni con a bordo oltre 100 persone
che non hanno neanche il carburante
sufficiente per percorrere 20 miglia in
mare vengono caricati verso l'europa
sono oltre 2000 i migranti morti in mare
dall'inizio dell'anno
ecco un'immagine scattata la settimana
scorsa quella notturna
notturna che vedevamo prima scattata
l'immagine la settimana scorsa durante
un'operazione di soccorso da parte dei
medici senza frontiere al largo delle
coste libiche a bordo di queste
imbarcazioni messe mare dai trafficanti
la morte la si sfiora e tante volte nel
corso di pochi miglia ea bordo della
ford prudence di medici senza frontiere
i tanti sorrisi di chi ce l'ha fatta
suonano chiari come la semplice parola
grazie e forse il sorriso è l'unica
parola su cui io non mi sia mai
interrogata
[Applauso]